thank you
well hello hi convection elations thanks
for taking the time out I know you guys
are must be really really busy but um
making can you tell this what it's like
becoming a new mum and tell us a little
bit about baby saw success we calling it
magic it's pretty amazing
and I have the two best guys in the
world so I'm
tell us a little bit about um your son
what's what's he like his easy sleeping
world with baby yes he has the sweetest
temperament he's really calm
[Music]
an easement has just been the dream
it's been a special couple days
who does he take off does he look like
anyone
though everyone says that baby's changed
so much over two weeks we've basically
sort of monitoring how they are changing
process happens over this next month
really he's changed his looks are
changing every single day so who knows
and how you find parroting generally
that's it is it still special moment
yeah that's great I mean parenting is
amazing is it's only been what two and a
half days three days but we just were
just so thrilled to have have our own
little bundle of joy
dispensing precious times with him as
his thing slowly starts to grow up and I
hate like to see two special people in
the minutes yes
cravings and the June yes and we just
bumped into the Jupiter walking by which
was so nice so it'll be a nice moment
reduce the baby to more fan
no another great grandchild just can't
quite see his face
deserting a little bit of facial hair as
well wonderful thank you so much of hug
thank you and thank you everybody for
all the well wishes and the kindness
it's just